Julian Rizzo asks what is magnetism how
two magnets work I know there's those
things that stick to your fridge but the
force is all around us and protects us
from solar bursts I like that that's at
the end of the questions a question yes
that's true he's in the band insane
clown posse never it was really
reference I guys know that a song about
magnets it was really the early stuff
now they're just completely over
produced but that said yeah magnetism is
generally thought of as a current a flow
of electrons which have an electric
field which induces a magnetic field
through a term coined by my personal
hero Michael Faraday all one word
electromagnetism no mass you're an
engineer yeah you took a lot of physics
I did but I'm just amazed to hear this
is Bill Nye the Science Guy explain
magnetism honest I can't yes we go with
the physics when we have a prior light
well we have a permanent school we think
of a virtual current that is to say it's
as though there's a current flowing in
the magnetic material yes iron cobalt
nickel yeah or some of these fabulous
rare earths but in the earth which was
which the questioner referred to to
which the question referred in the earth
we have somehow a spinning giant mass of
by our standards very large mass of
molten iron which carries a lot of
electrons which are in motion which
induce a current which creates a
magnetic features very important for our
survival it keeps our atmosphere in
place it we're really a whole our
atmosphere is kept here by magnets
partially so yes if we did not have our
magnetic field we would infect us some
theories if you look at Mars which does
not have a magnetic field that why did
Earth survive
and as far as we know at least on the
surface there's nothing obvious that's
looking more Mars's core with
a hot giant ball of iron that's spun
what it's been naturally if it was there
well Marge is spinning at about the same
solutions we get in a magnetic field it
might have had a different destiny could
it be in an atmosphere be created if a
magnetic field was added to it or might
be be able to be captured possibly okay
so it's generally believed that since
Mars was - was smaller than the earth it
radiated more heat into space cooled off
solidified and any molten motion of
metal inside came to a standstill and
then the solar wind little particles
streaming off the Sun stripped the
Martian atmosphere away and while we all
sit here mm-hmm just a couple weeks ago
I went to Cape Canaveral for the launch
of the maven mission cool Mars
atmospheric volatile evolution mmm
spacecraft it's a tortured acronym but
they're going to assess the Alacran it
isn't Kulak maven is pretty good it's
pretty good they're going to assess the
atmosphere learn more about the
atmosphere of Mars and what happened
there why Mars is different from the
earth and that will I guarantee you
questioner that will tell us more about
us and our dare I say it place in space
so so what I'm getting from this is
theoretically we could create an
atmosphere on another planet using a
great deal of iron and a bunch of
various and scuba tanks scuba days
physically scuba tanks a handful of
whales all right but a magnetic field is
very important it's the deal then we do
the thing from search for Spock where we
bioengineer planet but okay never you've
got a crazy plan there that is great you
gene but it I have the same I don't know
what are you talking about but it sounds
good
it's not that crazy of you I'm looking
at Bill Nye the Science Guy just to know
for confirmation honest but it sounds
good all right when you start getting
into the Star Trek movies yeah there's
gonna be some inconsistencies
terraforming a planet is just not that
easy but it's not I'm not saying it's
easy you know saying here's a few ways
we could do it don't underestimate the
magnetic field exactly well set awesome